[Music]
after many adventures in wonderland
alice has once again found herself in
the court of the temperamental queen of
hearts she's about to pass through the
garden undetected when she overhears the
king and queen arguing it's quite simple
says the queen 64 is the same as 65 and
that's that
without thinking alice interjects
nonsense she says if 64 were the same as
65 then it would be 65 and not 64 at all
what how dare you the queen huffs i'll
prove it right now and then it's off
with your head
before she can protest alice is dragged
toward a field with two chessboard
patterns an eight by eight square and a
five by thirteen rectangle as the queen
claps her hands four odd looking
soldiers approach and lie down next to
each other covering the first chessboard
alice sees that two of them are
trapezoids with non-diagonal sides
measuring five by five by three while
the other two are long triangles with
non-diagonal sides measuring eight by
three
see this is 64. the queen claps her
hands again the card soldiers get up
rearrange themselves and lie down atop
the second chessboard and that is 65.
alice gasps she's certain the soldiers
didn't change size or shape moving from
one board to the other but it's a
mathematical certainty that the queen
must be cheating somehow can alice wrap
her head around what's wrong before she
loses it
just as things aren't looking too good
for alice she remembers her geometry and
looks again at the trapezoid and
triangle soldier lying next to each
other
they look like they cover exactly half
of the rectangle they're edges forming
one long line running from corner to
corner
if that's true then the slopes of their
diagonal sides should be the same but
when she calculates these slopes using
the tried and true formula rise over run
a most curious thing happens
the trapezoid soldier's diagonal side
goes up 2 and over 5 giving it a slope
of two-fifths or 0.4
the triangle soldier's diagonal however
goes up 3 and over 8 making its slope 3
8 or 0.375
they're not the same at all
before the queen's guards can stop her
alice drinks a bit of her shrinking
potion to go in for a closer look sure
enough there's a minuscule gap between
the triangles and trapezoids forming a
parallelogram that stretches the entire
length of the board and accounts for the
missing square
there's something even more curious
about these numbers they're all part of
the fibonacci series where each number
is the sum of the two preceding ones
fibonacci numbers have two properties
that factor in here
first squaring a fibonacci number gives
you a value that's one more or one less
than the product of the fibonacci
numbers on either side of it in other
words eight squared is one less than
five times thirteen while five squared
is one more than three times eight
and second the ratio between successive
fibonacci numbers is quite similar
so similar in fact that it eventually
converges on the golden ratio that's
what allows devious royals to construct
slopes that look deceptively similar in
fact the queen of hearts could cobble
together an analogous conundrum out of
any four consecutive fibonacci numbers
the higher they go the more it seems
like the impossible is true but in the
words of lewis carroll author of alice
in wonderland and an accomplished
mathematician who studied this very
puzzle
one can't believe impossible things
you can prepare yourself to confront the
seemingly impossible by using brilliant
brilliant is a problem-solving based
platform with dozens of courses in math
science and computer science it has
everything from interactive logic
challenges to lessons on how the
algorithms behind search engines work
and much much more you can try it out
today at brilliant.org ted ed as an
added bonus the first 833 of you to
visit using that link will receive 20
off the annual premium subscription fee
[Music]